برميل على الاقل من النفط الخام
الروسي منذ غزو اوكرانيا بعد ان
الكيانات الروسية. الرئيس
الاوكراني يؤكد تمسكه بالمفاوضات
وحذر المصدر المسؤول في الفصائل
ان هذا الاستفزاز للمسلمين سيكون
الهند على تنويع مصادر الطاقة.
وكانت الهند قد اشترت عشر مليون
جادة في العودة الى الاتفاق
النووي. وزيرة الخارجية
المخابرات العسكرية البريطانية
ان القوات الروسية تواصل استخدام
سيدة فلسطينية في بيت لحم بعد ان
قتلوها. زيلانسكي اوكرانيا تحملت
تتوعد بوتين بعد مجزرة بوتشا.
الفصائل الفلسطينية مخطط
عناء حرب لها روسيا لمدة عشر
سنوات. رئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية
بريطانيا تكشف تكتيكا روسيا
خطيرا في حرب اوكرانيا. واعلنت
الايراني من لائحة الارهاب بعدما
كانت واشنطن اشارت الى قرب
التوصل الى تفاهم مع ايران حول
احياء الاتفاق النووي المبرم في
اوكرانيا تضع حدا لتوسع امريكا
الطائش ان بلاده لن تخضع للحرب
من ايراني. يتهم روسيا بالتخطيط
لاستخدام السلاح الكيماوي.
مؤشر على تحقيق تقدم في الملف
بعدما افرجت ايران عن بريطانيين
المحترف. يبدو ان بوتين يريد حسم
معركة الدومبا سريعا بدفعه
الاستسلام. فهل يستمر الغرب
بدعمه السخي هذا حتى تخرج كييف
الغرب وامريكا يعيدون اوكرانيا
الى الواجهة بعد ان كانت على وشك
ماريبول. روسيا محارق جثث متنقلة
لاحراق جثث الضحايا بالمدينة.
المستوطنين لذبح القرابين داخل
المسجد الاقصى يعتبر لعبا بالنار
بداية ايام سوداء على الاحتلال
ومستوطنيه وفق تعبيره عمدة
وفرص الحل الدبلوماسي للحرب.
جنود اسرائيليون يحاصرون جثمان
نزرع. قائد جديد للقوات الروسية
في اوكرانيا. اليد الضاربة
ازمة القمح والحبوب بسبب الحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية بالزراعة
امريكا. قلق في اليمن التي
تستورد نصف قمحها من روسيا
العبوات الناسفة لاحداث خسائر
بشرية واضعاف الروح المعنوية
وتقييد حرية تحرك الاوكرانيين.
ايران تطالب برفع الضغوط القصوى.
ابدا. اسرائيل ترحب بالتراجع
الامريكي عن ازالة الحرس الثوري
اغرتها التخفيضات الكبيرة في
اعقاب العقوبات الغربية على
ليس من مصلحتكم شراء مزيد من
النفط الروسي. ومستعدون لمساعدة
كنا سنتوصل الى اتفاق ام لا. لان
واشنطن لم تظهر حتى الان انها
الالمانية تدعو الى تسليم اسلحة
ثقيلة لاوكرانيا. بايدن للهند
وتحقيق نتائج هائلة في هذا
الجانب وتحت شعار سنأكل مما
مضادة للطائرات وذلك في اطار
عملية شبه سرية وسط مخاوف من
نختفي ببطء. وتابع الفوج متوجها
الى الاوكرانيين. لنعلم ما الذي
بتعويض الطاقة الروسية بطاقة
بديلة لكن هذا الامر لم يقنع
ان حظر الطاقة الروسية لن يوقف
الحرب. الدول الاوروبية تعاني
ايضا ترفض الحظر تماما. لكن غير
ذلك فهناك دول وافقت على استيراد
الطولى للصين وتأثيرها العالمي.
انقسام غربي. المسؤول الاوروبي
وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجية
الايرانية لا نعرف حقا ما اذا
الثانية في الشيشان يصفه
المسئولون الامريكيون بالضابط
الفين وخمسة عشر. ويحد من برنامج
طهران للاسلحة النووية في احدث
لبوتين. بوتين قد منحه ميدالية
بطل روسيا عام الفين وستة عشر
رئيسا للوزراء خلفا لعمران خان
حجبت عنه ثقة البرلمان بدعم
واوكرانيا واتجاه لتحقيق
الاكتفاء الذاتي. اليمن يواجه
الجنرال فورنيكوف الى ارض
المعركة. لافروف الحرب في
الجنرال بورنيكوف الذي تربى على
العقائد السوفيتي وقتل في الحرب
موسكو بدفع القيمة بالروبل
الروسي. والتطورات. الرئيس
الروسي في ماريو بول. مقتل احد
عشر مدنيا بقصف روسي استهدف محطة
لا يقل عن دولتين من اعضاء حلف
وهما تركيا وبلغاريا يعكس اليد
الشيشاني قديروف يعود للظهور
ويهدد بمهاجمة ماريوبول ويتوعد
في ماري بول. القوات الاوكرانية
تقول انها امام خيارين اما الموت
لهذه المعركة. مع اقتراب ساعة
الصفر للمعركة الحاسمة والاخيرة
قطار تجارية بخاركيف. البرلمان
الباكستاني ينتخب شهباز شريف
اوروبا بعد التي قد تحرم من
الغاز ان هي حاولت الا تنفذ شرط
بدخول العاصمة الاوكرانية كييف.
كتيبة ازوف تستهدف مواقع للجيش
الحالي المتوتر في تسلمت صربيا
حليفة الصين منظومة صينية متطورة
تسبب عملية حشد الاسلحة في
البلقان في تهديد السلام الهش في
في بيان له اليوم ستكون على
الارجح المعركة الاخيرة. لان
سيحصل لكننا نطلب منكم حقا ان
تتذكرونا بكلمة طيبة. حليف روسيا
حدود لكييف لكنه يخاف ان تخسر
روسيا الحرب او ان تتوسع رقعة
واضحا بقدر وضوح تناقض واشنطن.
فالبيت الابيض يقدم دعما بلا
المحايد لاوكرانيا لترد اوكرانيا
ان الزيلينسكي كان قد ابدى
ايضا الى خمسة مليارات دولار.
والدعم الامريكي هذه المرة يوضح
الحرب. ما هذا الانفصام في
الشخصية الامريكية الذي يحير
العالم. سقوط وشيك. زيلانسكي
يتوقع معركة كبيرة جدا شرق
نظامها الذي بنته خلال العشرين
عاما الماضية. لكن كل ذلك ليس
الطاقة من موسكو بالروبل الروسي.
خوف اوروبي مع وعود امريكا
يحظر استيراد الطاقة ودول اخرى
تريد فرض هذا الحظر ودول اخرى
انقساما واضحا في هذا الخصوص.
فبعض الدول تتريث في فرض قانون
وبين روسيا ورفضت اتفاق السلام
وانسحبت من كل التعهدات بعد ان
كانت قد طلبت وقفا فوريا لاطلاق
النار مقابل موافقتها على بعض
يوما لكنه استعداد القوات
الاوكرانية المقدرة باربعين الفا
او الاسر. وكتب الفوج السادس
والثلاثون في البحرية الاوكرانية
جوزيف بوريل يكسر حصار الوهم
بشأن حظر الطاقة الروسية بقوله
الخبراء ان ارسال الصين اسلحة
الى دولة صربيا مرورا باراضي ما
تلك المنطقة. في الوقت الذي تدور
فيه رحى الحرب في اوكرانيا. ويرى
فالمسيرات دقيقة جدا وقد تكون
بقدرات اقوى من البرقدار التركية
وصواريخ المضادة للدبابات
والمدفعيات والاليات العسكرية.
سيصل لمبلغ ثلاثة مليارات دولار.
اما دعم حلف الناتو لكييف سيصل
الذاتي بعيدا عن معمعات حرب
اوكرانيا. الواقع السياسي. اتهام
تعيينه? مفاوضات ايران تعاني
الموت السريري وعمران خان يفقد
ثقة برلمانه مع انتخاب بديل له.
اما المقاومة الفلسطينية فتطلق
شروط موسكو في حين عادت هذه
المرة ورفضتها. الدعم الامريكي
القوي. الصين ترسل دفعة من
الامدادات العسكرية المنتظمة الى
صربيا مع التشديد على ان تلك
الامدادات لا صلة لها بالوضع
ذخائرنا تنفد سيكون مصير بعضنا
الموت والبعض الاخر الاسر. نحن
تهديدا صريحا للمحتل الاسرائيلي.
واليمنيون يسعون لتحقيق الاكتفاء
استعداد بلاده لبحث قضية ان تكون
اوكرانيا دولة محايدة مع روسيا
لقواته على الارض الاوكرانية.
فمن هو هذا الجنرال وما هو سبب
انقساما في اوروبا بسبب النفط
والغاز. بوتين يعين قائدا جديدا
لنا ان امريكا لم تعد تقدم دعما
دفاعيا فقط بل هجوميا ايضا.
والخلاصة ان الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية لن تدع روسيا تفسد
اوكرانيا تحديدا في ماريبول
المحاصرة منذ اكثر من اربعين
وفقدان الامل. اوروبا تكسر وهم
حظر الطاقة الروسي في تحدث موسكو
لكن موسكو ترى ان اوكرانيا رفضت
تطبيق المعاهدات التي وقعت بينها
الى صربيا حليفة روسيا في عملية
شبه سرية. فهل تكون هذه العملية
من عنق الزجاجة? ام ان للروس
كلاما اخر?
دعم امريكي وغربي يعيد الحياة
لاوكرانيا. فهل يكون هذا الدعم
بداية خطة لدعم صيني لروسيا?
ماري بول ما بين معركة اخيرة
روسي للرئيس الاوكرانيسكي بالكذب
بشأن استعداده لمناقشة الوضع
طوق نجاة ام زيادة في معاناة
الاوكرانيين. الصين ترسل اسلحة